but bounce right back up Oh rocket odds  all looks much more comfortable tonight  turnaround jump shot with jeans so far  here tonight you know Ron from Phoenix  as they take a 300 lead and second  quarter 6255 they have been red-hot is  great to see both sons debut thought  about another three  instead it's right down to the last  second had to get it up quickly while  working on the lopez screen Glenn's  hands across stolen by Lopez touch pass  to danced until the three-point zone  Fulton Holland is donating $100 to some  charity  all his ride go through the left hand  reverse in need of a couple of stops  ball wide open down the lane nobody  closed in defensively in Alonso ball has  scored the last six Laker